In this video we shall review how to manage scheduled scans. If you schedule a recurring
scan Burps with Enterprise Edition displays stats and charts that enable you to track your progress
over time. This enables you to identify areas for improvement and to see changes in your security
posture. You can use the scheduled scans page to view and edit the schedule for recurring scans.
In order to view scheduled scans select the scans tab and scheduled scans. This will give you a list
of all scans that have been scheduled. We can then select a scheduled scan and we'll see the start
time, the recurrence and the next run. If required we can edit the schedule. We can select a different
schedule, how we're going to repeat the scan and if that's going to be forever, a set number of times,
or until a particular date. Additionally, if we want to delete the scan we can select delete schedule.
Please note that the scan configuration panel is not displayed for schedules created on Burps
with Enterprise Edition 2022.4 or later, or those schedules that did not already have scan configurations
assigned at the time of upgrading to that release. For scans using these schedules you should define
scan settings at the site level. Thank you.